We've been digging into the
decipherment of ancient scripts,
but what is a script
[inaudible]
I'm convinced we'll miss a lot along our
journey into decipherment if we don't
pack an understanding of writing
systems to take along with us.
So at this point,
I plan to spend a few minutes racing
over the basics of writing with you,
but however hard I tried to
condense it and pack it in,
it's scratched for more scratched.
The old Greek root for writing graph
meant scratch like scratching symbols into
rock or clay graph.
Femes are written units like
the Letter v, a Semicolon,
the hung character for fire.
The actual marks that get
written down are glyphs.
Here are some glyphs for the Grapheme
v and here are some glyphs for fire.
Little marks called diacritics
can modify those glyphs.
Here's an o with the nasal mark telling
you to pronounce it through the nose.
Oh, here's that same
diacritic above the letter.
A diacritics are often simplified or
miniature versions of other glyphs.
So that little nasal mark comes from the
letter n put a top on other character.
Notice that a single grapheme can
be written with various glyphs.
These glyphs are all allographs
other scratches of the Grapheme v.
of fire. Very roughly.
A set of graphemes that get used
together in writing makeup. A script,
a script together with the weighting
codes or represents language is a writing
system. Graph. Phoenix
wonders about writing system,
things like the use of certain symbols
for certain sounds or certain meanings or
the differences between different writing
systems. Then there's gruff FedEx,
which wants to know about things like
the shape and composition of letters or
the mechanics of human handwriting.
The word writing can mean any of these.
I really want to put some art in thought
into this separate voyage through
writing so that we can make the most
of decipherment tune in for both and
subscribed for language.
[inaudible].